this is the picture that has infuriated
the Indian government their pilots
blindfolded and bloodied shown in a
video shared by Pakistan's Information
Ministry Islamabad says they're treating
the pilot well later releasing another
video showing the airmen drinking tea
and chatting he was captured after his
plane was shot down by Pakistan Air
Force jets over the disputed region of
Kashmir this sharp escalation in
violence between the neighbors presents
the first test for Pakistan's newly
elected leader
Imran Khan Meera Somalia Hindustan local
would say my question to the Indian
government is can we really afford any
miscalculation
should we not be thinking from here if
it escalates where will this go it's not
in my control nor in Narendra Modi's
control the tension between the two
nuclear-armed countries has been
condemned by the EU and the UK
government says it's doing everything it
can to bring about a de-escalation in
the situation we have been working
around the clock to do everything we can
to encourage both sides to de-escalate
and reduce tensions I spoken to for mr.
Swaraj in India yesterday I had also
spoken to Pakistani Foreign Minister
Qureshi and there is no desire on either
side for this conflict to escalate
India and Pakistan have gone to war
twice over Kashmir and although there's
always tension along the line of control
the de facto border that Cleaves
Kashmiri
to the last major armed conflict was
back in 1999 in Kargil
since then and on Easy Pieces existed
with the threat of violence never far
you have seen for the first time aerial
engagement between the two air forces
where one or two planes may have been
destroyed we've never seen this in the
last 50 years
Pakistan accuses India's Hindu
nationalist Prime Minister Narendra Modi
of using this conflict to boost his
election prospects the nation goes to
the polls in the spring but the Indian
authorities say they are simply
defending themselves they accused
Pakistan of sheltering terrorist groups
including the one they blamed for
bombing a para military convoy in Burma
in February it was this attack that has
led to this current conflict ultimately
it could be the fate of this one pilot
that could change the direction of this
already extremely volatile situation
Ashish Joshi Sky News Delhi